ambassador Husain Haqqani of Pakistan to
the United States
welcome to Yale Husain Haqqani has been
a very very well-known figure in
Pakistan yes what for three prime
ministers and he has then been at
Carnegie Endowment for international
peace and then Boston University and now
he's the ambassador of Pakistan to the
United States so welcome to yell there
being a name let me ask you first having
served three prime ministers and with
all the experience you have how do you
see the sixth experiment with democracy
in Pakistan how has it started off how
do you see the prospect do you see it is
is this time six-time lucky well nine I
think that the reason why Pakistan has
not been able to build a democracy in
the past is because of the impatience of
its civil military elites and I think
this time around the International
factors the local factors and even the
perception of the elites in Pakistan is
very different if you go back in history
you will notice that Pakistan's first
military coup came within ten years of
Independence primarily because the civil
military elite felt that the
complications of working out a democracy
were not worth it that it was that
nation-building could be more easily
done under an authoritarian regime that
delusion lasted for quite a while but it
ended and we had our first elected
civilian government in the seventies
after that generals say all Huk
intercepted an inter that the process
and his argument was that Pakistan needs
to be an ideological state now both
those arguments that nation-building is
better than under authoritarianism and
that Pakistan is better off as an
ideological state defined by a small
group of
theocrats or theocratic aliy inclined
elites both have been proven to have
been mistakes the third attempt
at military intervention serious
attempters under General Musharraf and
gentleman should have basically
represented the notion that Pakistan can
be better run by a technocratic elite
and we have seen that dream in tatters
as well now I see no hug ument in favor
for thorat Arianism left in pakistan yes
there are some people who still say that
we have to be an ideological state so
that can be much better accomplished
under it benevolent dictator yes there
are a few people who still say that
maybe the government should be run by
technocrats and not by politicians but
there is great consensus in Pakistan
that to forge a Pakistani national
identity all Pakistani provinces all
Pakistani ethnic groups need to feel
that they are part of Pakistan and the
only way they will feel part of Pakistan
is through an electric democra
democratic process
second the technocrats also they
sometimes get purely technocratic
decisions right but they are unable to
bring the nation together and lastly
when it comes to the external factors
when general zia-ul-haq became
Pakistan's president in a military
uniform many countries in the world had
military governments when Musharraf
became Pakistan's ruler he was one of
two or three so now the international
momentum is also against military
dominated governance I think all those
factors have come together but most
important is the fact that this time the
restoration of democracy has come at a
very high price we lost benazir bhutto
who was much beloved and in her
assassination it's very interesting that
Gallup which did polling after that
showed that they had never been such an
enmity in Pakistani public opinion on
grief when her father was assassinated
some people didn't mind it when generals
l have died that there was a Pakistani
society was divided between those who
were fond of him and those who hated him
in Benazir Bhutto's assassination It was
as if a national dream had been killed
and and and most
leaders in Pakistan now are reconciled
to the fact that yes we will disagree
with one another but we will never help
another military coup so I think this
time there are many factors that will
strengthen Pakistan's evolution as a
democracy yeah I think the question
really is whether the Army is reconciled
to the loss of its authority that was
exercised through General Musharraf
especially recently the Army has
announced their plans to sell the land
it owns to build its general
headquarters now the question is does
the army have the right to sell the
state land to build his own headquarters
that's the kind of a small example of
the army acting as as if state within a
state
look let us go to the more fundamental
question Pakistan Pakistan needs a
military but what Pakistan needs is for
its military to work under civilian
Authority constitutional authority I
think that the new army chief and most
of his close commanders all realize that
the Army's professionalism suffered
immensely with the army being drawn into
politics will this transition be
instantaneous no it won't the Army has
been brought in in too many things and
it'll take some time to get out of them
but the important things that have
already started happening the army chief
General Ashfaq eonni has already
withdrawn all those serving military
officers who were filling up civilian
positions at government big change the
inter-services intelligence has shut
down its political wing major thing
because that was the instrument of
intervention in politics the army did
not play any role in trying to influence
the outcome of the February 18 election
or of the political process subsequent
to that because they didn't do anything
to influence the choice of prime
minister they did nothing
to influence the choice of president the
electoral processes have been taking on
their own their own dynamic and I think
that the things that you're talking
about about the military's sort of
having welfare schemes with economic
dimensions etc I think we will be able
to rationalize those over time as well
mm-hmm the other question that has been
raised is that General Musharraf is gone
but looks like the current government is
pursuing the same policies whether it is
the question of war on terror or
question of privatizing of state
organizations and even raising the price
of utilities as it has been pressed on
by the international financial
institutions in all these policies these
are very government seems to be pursuing
more sheriff's policies that may change
does a very gallant government
represents what is essentially a
national consensus on issues such as
privatization whether in mr. Nawaz
Sharif was in power whether General
Musharraf or the are the new elected
government and even the previous PPP
government led by benazir bhutto herself
none of them could do without
privatization for the simple reason that
Pakistan has just too many stained or
state-owned enterprises that are not
sufficiently efficient and it's much
easier for them to be sold off and their
value recovered for the benefit of
Pakistan's economy so privatization
falls in that category
similarly the question of raising prices
of utilities again basically it's a
question of market prices oil prices
have gone up the government has to pay
for the oil to buy it from the Gulf and
those that oil is then sold to the
utilities after all that has to be
recovered so that's a different category
as well it's not no sheriff's policy
it's the global markets policy the only
thing that is left is the water
and here's a big difference General
Musharraf said that we are fighting the
war against terror because America told
us to do so this government says that we
have to fight terrorism because
terrorism is a threat to Pakistan I
think that while the conduct of the war
is going on
the fact of the matter is that the war
aims have changed very seriously the aim
of General Musharraf was to please the
United States the aim of the elected
government is to work with the United
States and other allies to ensure
Pakistan's own safety and security and
to make sure that Pakistan is not seen
as or becomes a safe haven or a base for
extremist groups from around the world
so I think that the change of the
objective actually makes the policy very
different there's a very significant
change in the u.s. approach to Pakistan
with the July signing of President Bush
this secret national security directive
in which he authorized the US military
to actually intervene in Pakistan
without prior notification and the
result of which was the first attack on
Pakistani territory on November and
September third is this is a change
which follows the departure of Musharraf
the question is is it the new policy is
designed to put pressure on the civilian
government or is it this because the
u.s. elections are approaching and you
needed to do something against terrorism
in an Mortimer study boy what was the
purpose 9 first if the directive was as
I said signed in July then Musharraf was
still there so it wasn't post Musharraf
and I don't know if the directive has
been signed if it's a secret directive
the US government I'm sure can keep
secrets even though this won't seem to
keep them from the New York Times but
let me just say that the operation that
the US forces conducted on September 3rd
was a mistake it achieved no war him
they did not get any terrorists or
militants they did not manage to kill
al-qaeda leaders or the
Lebon and they only served to enrage the
Pakistani public since then we have
engaged with US officials we understand
political compulsions we come from
political backgrounds ourself president
sir that is a politician he understands
politics the two parties are engaged in
an election campaign fourth of November
the election is coming people are asking
what happened did we succeed in getting
Osama bin Laden and if not why not
so therefore for the in the context of
the campaign it makes sense for some
people but there's another dimension to
it also threat American troops in
Afghanistan and they are in harm's way
and they are attacked and when they are
attacked and they asked their of Ronn
counterparts why are we under attack
what's happening and they are told at
some of these Taliban and these al-qaeda
people are coming from Pakistan then all
the more reason they feel all the more
reason to want to do something about it
but all wars require intelligent actions
not just actions and the intelligent
thing to do is to let Pakistan take care
of the Pakistani side of the border
because if it escalates if American
troops get inducted they will have
another theater of war without
necessarily having any war eum's being
fulfilled we have spoken to the
Americans about this they now understand
that if Pakistan is willing to step up
to the plate which it is Pakistan wants
to step up action on its side of the
border we have paid a dear price even in
the past even under Musharraf hundreds
of Pakistanis were killed Pakistani
soldiers were killed but the problem was
that these soldiers were sent into
battle the Taliban without adequate
counterinsurgency training but elected
government has asked the United States
to help us get that counterinsurgency
training we have asked the u.s. to
provide us the equipment that is needed
for this kind of warfare
you see Pakistani soldiers have been
trained to fight a different kind of war
on a different border this is different
terrain so we need different type of
trained trained soldiers the mistake
under Musharraf was that the training
was not there the equipment was not
there the soldiers were sent in large
numbers and we had a we we sacrificed
many lives in the process
there's going to be an intelligent
warden I don't know if you've noticed in
the last two to three weeks in barge or
Pakistan has conducted a very methodical
operation from the area northwest from
Northwest Frontier bordering Afghanistan
bordering the corner province air power
has been deployed and because it has
been a methodical operation several
hundred militants and Taliban have been
killed and they are feeling the pressure
which is why they have started attacking
Pakistani cities again we will have to
bear that fear and we will have to do
something about protecting our cities
against the suicide bombers as well but
as President Zardari and prime minister
Yousaf Raza Gillani repeatedly say this
is Pakistan's war
we have to save Pakistan from becoming a
Taliban home the Taliban's vision is not
our vision the Taliban don't want young
women to ever receive an education
they've been blowing up schools in
Pakistan and more Pakistanis have been
killed by suicide bombers than Americans
have been killed so we don't look upon
this as an American war that we have to
fight to please America we are fighting
for our own nation for our own future
and I think as long as the Americans
understand that and notwithstanding any
specific directive or not the American
forces will stay on the one side of the
border and Afghanistan Pakistan the US
and NATO will work cooperatively in
making sure that terrorists are denied
an opportunity to organize and wage
attacks on both sides of the Pakistan of
Khan border you have mentioned in some
other occasion that President Musharraf
carried the policy of running with the
hair hunting in the hand in terms of
dealing with with terrorism why was that
why did he have this two facet policy on
terrorism well I think that it wasn't a
two-fisted policy in his perspective
what he was doing was he did first of
all you must understand that before 9/11
he didn't see terrorism as a menace in
itself which is very different from
benazir bhutto and mr. Ezard re who have
always seen terrorism as a threat
because they don't intellectually agree
with it General Musharraf
thought that this is just some
conventional warfare and it gives some
leverage in in in regional politics so
that was a point of view and after 9/11
it was very difficult for him to make
the major change he made medium to
short-term changes he understood that
you have to forsake the Taliban and and
and and that you have to curtail the
operation of militant groups on the
other side as well but having said that
from day one I don't know if you can
recall there are many interviews of his
there was a time when he used to argue
that the Taliban and al-qaeda need to be
treated differently then he started
saying of an Taliban and Pakistani
Taliban need to be he just never made
the transition from thinking of these
people as elements of a regional
strategic problem to elements of a
regional strategic design to thinking
that they are a problem and I think that
now presumes there are pawns that he
could play he thought that they were
pawns that he could play even after
attempts on his life he only thought
about okay the groups that are
responsible for attempting to trying to
kill me we need to go after them he
didn't understand that what needs to be
eliminated is the whole idea that
somehow blowing yourself up for a cause
is a good thing because very frankly
irrespective of the objective terrorism
is a nuisance and even and a problem and
a threat it's all of those things and
it's a menace terrorism needs to be
eliminated because it is a threat not
because terrorist is okay but terrorist
be is good there are no good terrorists
and bad terrorists and I think that the
Pakistani military leadership and the
Pakistani civilian leadership that has
been elected in February of this year
they understand that the they had made a
considerable improvement at least in in
appearance
relations between Afghanistan and
Pakistan
President Karzai and President Zardari
seem to get along well now has there
been any progress on the investigation
that General Kayani said was launching
into the allegation by the United States
and by India and that is I was involved
in the bombing of the Indian Embassy in
Kabul I think that we are working on
finding out the truth about the bombing
of the Indian Embassy in Kabul we will
have more details at some point in the
future but as of now we do understand
that that there was no conscious
decision on the part of any Pakistani
organization to be part of it this was a
terrorist act and if those terrorists
are in any part of Pakistan including
the tribal areas the Pakistani
government will definitely act against
them the important thing is that
President Zardari has articulated a
vision his vision is one of close ties
with Afghanistan and friendship with
India while we have disagreements with
India while we have the outstanding
dispute of Jammu and Kashmir we would
still want to normalize relations with
them because again it is more important
to move forward and to have less
pressures on Pakistan from the external
side and India and Pakistan together can
have many economic benefits for each
other
Afghanistan and Pakistan together can
definitely strengthen each other as
nations and we have historic relations
let us be honest India and Pakistan have
5,000 years of common history and 60
years of partition of Han Astana and
Pakistan have hundreds of years of
common history so there's no reason why
we should be stuck in adversarial mode
and not find commonalities upon which we
can work together that said we will
occasionally disagree President Karzai
and President Zardari will also disagree
by Prime Minister Manmohan Singh and
presence is that he will disagree but
but there has to be a fundamental
difference in approaching each other as
permanent enemies or looking upon each
other as neighbors
who can deal with issues on an
issue-by-issue basis
how would Kashmir what has what's the
position of President Zardari and Prime
Minister Gilani as to how to move
forward again on Kashmir which has been
kind of well I think that India and
Pakistan both have to find creative
solutions to the Kashmir problem there
are strong emotions in Pakistan on the
Kashmir issue I'm sure there are strong
views in India on Kashmir issue and then
the people of Kashmir they have a their
position and their point of view needs
to be heard they need to be part of the
solution the important thing is that the
bilateral engagement of India and
Pakistan should not be should not be
stopped because we are not making
progress on the issue of Jammu and
Kashmir but the issue of Jammu and
Kashmir should not be completely ignored
so we have to find ways of engaging and
at the same time finding solutions to
this dispute that has bedeviled
relationship between our two countries
the difference is that there are people
in Pakistan who have argued that if we
cannot have a solution to Kashmir
we need not have forward movement with
India I think that we can continue to
engage and at the same time look for a
solution I personally do not have a
solution to offer right now but in terms
of engaging what are the areas you think
Pakistan and India could engage and and
and the impact of their engagement would
be positive on other issues let me just
say that we need to have a very sensible
approach to resolving the search in
Glacier dispute both sides lose more
people to frostbite in those glaciers
then in actual fighting so it's in the
interest of both sides to try and find a
solution to that solution is almost
there it's a time it's a question of
signing it and moving on the sir Creek
issue that's also something that can be
resolved this is on the border
vielen synth basically it's a
demarcation issue
my point is reduced the portfolio of
disputes third move forward on bilateral
trade open up trade more
people-to-people contacts we need to
expand the range of contacts between the
two people whenever indians and
pakistanis meet whether it's over a
curry or over a cricket match or or or a
masala movie they always manage to be
able to talk to each other
in a much more friendly way than they
can when they are just dealing with
politics so I think that the
people-to-people contacts need to be
expanded in terms of trade we must
understand that once the Indian market
opens for Pakistani products Pakistan
gets access to a 1 billion strong market
and so there are opportunities for
Pakistan there are synergies between our
countries above all Pakistan is the
energy corridor for India if there is an
Iran India pipeline it will have to go
through Pakistan if there is a
Turkmenistan India pipeline it will have
to go through Afghanistan and Pakistan
if there is a pipeline from the Gulf
it'll have to go through Pakistan so all
of those things are the basis through
which we can hopefully open up our
relationship and have left issues of
hostility and more basis for cooperation
the final question coming back to the
United States the presidential debate
yesterday a lot of focus on foreign
affairs was devoted to your country how
do you think that these two presidential
candidates they are vision of Pakistan
and how to deal with the problem how do
you see that I think that it would not
be appropriate for me to insert myself
into the American political debate but
let me say one thing as ambassador I am
personally engaged with both campaigns
the advisors that president that senator
Obama and Senator McCain have both of
them have listened to our point of view
we have listened to theirs
Paxton is important for the next
president whoever he may be
Paxton is important for the United
States while we are not completely happy
with the tone of the conversation about
Pakistan these days it's important that
for the first time
Pakistan is receiving the attention that
it deserves now you and I have known
each other for many years Pakistan has
always been seen as in the context of
india-pakistan relations or during the
Soviet War in the context of the war
against the Soviets in Afghanistan or in
the war context of the war against
terrorism it's about time that the u.s.
beat attention to Pakistan in its own
right a nation of 160 million people
with a very strong army and nuclear
weapons with the potential for being a
moderate democratic tolerant pluralist
state while at the same time having the
threat of terrorism and militancy
Senator Joseph Biden is the author of a
bill called the Biden lugar bill which
expects to in triple civilian economic
aid to Pakistan 1.5 billion dollars
every year for five years and possibly
for 10 years as a long-term engagement
with Pakistan so that Pakistan is know
that the United States is a friend of
Pakistan I think it's time for Pakistan
in the United States to move away from
their short-term quit throwing quid pro
quo engagements and develop a strategic
partnership for peace in that region and
for consolidation of Pakistani democracy
and strengthening of Pakistani democracy
and I think that while there will be
disagreements between candidates on how
to do that I think the important thing
is that both presidential candidates in
the United States understand the
importance of Pakistan and they also
understand that for stability in
Pakistan there must be democracy and
that Pakistan stability is important to
American security thank you very much as
you're talking to you thank you